YURI GRINSHTEYN: We use
SLOs in error budgets
to set appropriate reliability
targets for our services.
But what happens when
there's an issue?
When you set up
a learning to let
us know that users are unhappy?
Today I want to show you how
to use error budget burner
alerts in Service Monitoring.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've covered using
threshold-based alerting
before, but learning on
SLOs is a bit different.
The main thing to
keep in mind is
that we want our alert to fire
long before our services out
of SLO, essentially as soon as
we start burning error budget.
To start, let's cover some math.
To help us, let's review chapter
five of the SRE workbook,
called Alerting on SLOs.
If you haven't read
it before, no worries.
We'll link to it in the
episode notes below.
As covered in that chapter,
your learning strategy
should include four
considerations.
They are precision-- what
fraction of your alerts
are actually triggered by a
real or significant event?
Recall-- what fraction of your
events results in an alert?
Detection time-- how long
does it take for an alert
to fire once an event starts?
And reset time-- how long
after the event is over
does it take for
your alert to reset?
There's no right values
for these considerations.
It all depends on what
you want out of alerts.
However, you'll probably want to
find the right balance for you
while minimizing your
operational load--
that is, the number
of alerts you actually
receive and have to respond to.
The best way to do this is
by alerting on error budget
burn rate, which is
where the math comes in.
Error budget burn
rate is a measure
of how fast,
relative to your SLO,
your service consumes
error budget.
For example, a service that
has exactly zero budget
left at the end of the
SLO evaluation period
has a burn rate of one.
A service that consumes
all of its error budget
halfway through the
evaluation period
has a burn rate
of two, and so on.
We calculate our burn rate by
looking at three main inputs--
the SLO and its
evaluation period,
the amount of error
budget consumed or burned,
and the window over
which that burn happens.
That's the alerting window.
This, then, is
the equation we'll
use to calculate burn rate that
we'll use when we configure
our error budget burn alerts.
Our burn rate is the amount
of error budget consumed
by the service multiplied
by the SLO evaluation period
and divided by the
alerting window.
OK.
That was a lot.
If you're a bit lost at this
point, that's totally OK.
All you really
need to understand
is that we can calculate
the error budget burn rate
if we know what our SLO is and
how much of our error budget
we want to consume and over what
time before firing our alert.
The next question you
might have is, well,
how much error budget
should my service
burn before firing an alert?
Here, we again return
to the alerting on SLOs
chapter of the SRE workbook
for two simple recommendations.
They are 2% of error
budget in one hour
and 5% of error
budget in six hours.
This way, you can both catch
higher error rates quickly
and lower error rates over
time without overwhelming
the on-callers with alerts.
Let's walk through
a specific example.
Let's say our service
has an availability
SLO of 95% over a
rolling 28-day window,
and we want to
create an alert that
lets us know if we've consumed
2% of our error budget
in the last hour.
We use our simple equation
to calculate the burn rate
we need to hit, which is 13.44.
Let's use the same equation
to calculate the burn rate
threshold for our other alert,
5% of our budget in six hours.
This time, our rate is 5.6.
OK.
So far, we've covered
our budget burn rates
and how we calculate them.
We're now ready to
set up our alerts.
Here's our service with our
SLO configured against it.
We're going to
create an alert that
lets us know when the service
consumes 2% of its error budget
in an hour.
This is where our budget
burn rate becomes important.
To configure the alert, we need
to specify the lookback window.
In our case, it's 60 minutes.
We also need to
specify the burn rate
we expect to hit during the
window as our threshold.
Remember, we already
calculated that to be 13.44.
Now, when our
service has an issue,
we'll see the error
budget decrease,
and we'll get an alert that
looks like this, showing us
the error budget burn
during the incident.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered a lot.
We learned about the
considerations that
should go into your
learning strategies,
and why alerting on
error budget burn
is a great way to balance them
against operational overload.
We then figured out how
to calculate their budget
burn rates, and
saw how to use them
to set up alerting for your
services in Service Monitoring.
Thanks so much for watching,
come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]